première étape de cette consultation les
cahiers de doléances jusqu'au 20 février
les yvelinoises et les yvelinois ont pu
se rendre dans leurs mairies et inscrire
leurs idées dans ses registres
que vont devenir les cahiers de
doléances les maires des communes devait
les transmettre à la préfecture des
yvelines avant le 22 février
environ 120 cahier d'expression
citoyenne ont été centralisés dans notre
département
la bibliothèque nationale de france est
ensuite chargé de les référencer et de
numériser leurs contenus combien de
réunions d'initiatives locales ont été
organisées
menés par des citoyens attrape ou par
des élus à poissy ces réunions se sont
déroulées aux quatre coins du
département depuis le 15 janvier
les participants se sont penchés sur les
thématiques proposées par le
gouvernement à savoir la transition
écologique la fiscalité la démocratie
citoyenne ou encore l'organisation de
l'état selon les chiffres de la
préfecture au 21 février dans les
yvelines 167 réunion d'initiatives
locales ont été programmés au réaliser
peut-on encore participer jusqu'au 15
mars vous avez trois possibilités
assister aux réunions d'initiative
locale contribuer sur la plateforme en
ligne ou bien transmettre votre
contribution par voie postale à
l'adresse qui s'affiche à l'écran
enfin le département des yvelines
accueillera les 26 et 27 février des
stands de proximité itinérant la gare de
versailles chantiers animé par des
étudiants
ils ont pour objectif de recueillir la
parole citoyenne de personnes qui
n'auraient pas encore contribué au débat